AMERICANS ARE FED UP WITH
CORPORATIONS PUSHING POLITICS
FROM COCA-COLA TO MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL AND IT SEEMS LIKE
LIBERAL IDEOLOGY IS CREEPING AN
EVERYWHERE.
JUST THIS WEEK AMERICAN EXPRESS
GOT CALLED UP FOR TELLING
EMPLOYEES CAPITALISM IS RACIST.
ENTREPRENEUR IS EXPOSING HEALTH
STATE COMPANIES MIX POLITICS
WITH THIS THIS AND USE IT TO
INFLUENCE OUR LIVES.
HE HAS A NEW BOOK COMING UP AND
A SPECIAL AIRING THIS SUNDAY ON
FOX NEWS AND IT WILL ALSO BE
AVAILABLE ON FOX NATION THAT DAY
.
HERE'S A PREVIEW.
>> I THINK THERE IS NOW A
CHINESE WORD FOR WHAT --
THEY UNDERSTAND THIS GAME FAR
MORE DEEPLY THAN ANY OF US DO.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE NOW USING
WOKISM AS A POLITICAL TOOL TO
ADVANCE THEIR OWN AGENDA.
>> THERE'S NOTHING LIKE GETTING
IT WRONG HERE.
IF WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE THINGS
THAT MATTER, THE BALANCE USE
THAT THE FOUNDERS LEFT US IN TH
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR REPUBLIC,
THEN THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WIL
HAVE THE SPACE.
>> THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
.
HOW BAD DOES NOT GET BEFORE
CORPORATIONS STOP DOING THIS.
>> HOW BAD IT IS GOTTEN IS
ACTUALLY FEEDING EVEN WORSE
BEHAVIOR GOING FORWARD.
THAT IS WHAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT
.
THEY ARE DOING WHAT ALLOWS THEM
TO MAKE THE MOST MONEY AT THE
EXPENSE OF AMERICAN --
THEY WILL GO TO CHINA AND THAT
SAY ABOUT IT PEOPLE ABOUT
INJUSTICE IN CHINA WITH TALK
ABOUT ALLEGED INJUSTICE HERE
WHAT HAS POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES.
THAT'S JUST THE FIRST PART OF IT
.
THE REAL THREAT THAT I TALK
ABOUT IS THIS IS A THREAT TO
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY, AND EACH OF
US SHOULD HAVE A SAY IN WHAT
CONSTITUTES OUR MORAL VALUES
RATHER THAN A SMALL GROUP OF
CEOS AND INVESTORS.
>> HE RUN MY SHOW A COUPLE WEEK
AGO AND TALK ABOUT HOW THAT THI
WAS A MISDIRECTION, THAT BEING
CORPORATIONS GO WOKE SO YOU
DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO THE
PROFITS THEY MAKE IN THE HIGH
INTEREST RATES AND THEIR SLOGAN
LIKE MEMBERSHIP HAS ITS
PRIVILEGES.
AS A REFLECTION OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES SOME PRIVILEGE, THEY
ARE CHARGING HIGH INTEREST RATES
.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS
BEAT THEM AT THE BLITZ.
LOOK OVER HERE WHILE WE CAN
STILL DO THIS.
SO I THOUGHT HAD AN IDEA, BUT I
WE ASKED AMERICAN EXPRESS TO PU
THEIR MONEY WHERE THEIR MOUTH I
AND CANCEL CREDIT CARD DEBT,
$800 BILLION.
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE IN SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND EQUITY, WHY DON'T
YOU DO THE RIGHT THING.
IT IS LIKE FIVE BY AMERICANS AR
HAVING AN AVERAGE IT FIVE GRAND
UP DEBT.
BY DON'T THEY DO THAT.
>> YOU JUST NAILED IT, GREG.
THEY BLOW WOKE SMOKE AND WHAT
RATHER NOT HAVE US TALK ABOUT
THIS.
THE PART OF THE THING ABOUT
AMERICAN EXPRESS IS THAT THEIR
BLACK CARD DOESN'T APPLY TO
BLACK PEOPLE.
APPLIES TO PEOPLE WHO SPEND
MILLIONS PER YEAR SO THERE'S TH
FIRST COMMANDMENT OF --
THE MORE WOKE YET ACT.
THAT IS THE CHARADE.
IT MY THINK THE FIRST STEP IN
SOLVING THE PROBLEM IS ACTUALLY
JUST PUTTING SOME SUMMIT ON THE
ISSUE.
WOULDN'T SOME LIGHT ON THE ISSU
EXPOSE THE HYPOCRISY.
>> I HAVE TO CORRECT YOU BECAUS
IT'S NOT SMOKE BECAUSE SMOKE
RAISES THE EARTH'S TEMPERATURE.
IT IS A HARMLESS VAPOR.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE IS ONE OF
THEIR FAVORITES.
ESPECIALLY THE IMPACT OF CLIMAT
CHANGE WHICH IS A WAY OF
CHANGING THE TOPIC FROM ECONOMI
INJUSTICE, WHICH THEY LOVE TO DO
.
>> IT IS ENVIRONMENTAL PLACES
HIM.
>> GREG HIT ON SOMETHING.
DO THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN --
THEY PROMISED $15 BILLION, ALL
THESE COMPANIES, AND THEY'VE
ONLY GIVEN OUT $250 MILLION.
SO IS THIS ALL ABOUT --
EMMA PUTTING THEIR MONEY WHERE
THEIR MOUTH IS QUICK.
>> I THINK IT'S MOSTLY --
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH VIRTUE
SIGNALING.
SIGNALING YOUR VIRTUE BECOMES
MORE IMPORTANT THAN BEING
VIRTUOUS ITSELF.
YOU TAKE A COMPANY WHICH TALKS
ABOUT THE LOSS OF INTERSECTION
ANALOGY, ACCORDING TO ITS CEO,
YET DOES NOT PAY ITS KEY PICKER
WHICH ARE RIGHT AND IN SOME
PLACES KILLED AND MAIMED BY
THEIR OWN COLLEAGUES, WHO ARE
NOW SEEKING JUSTICE FROM
UNILEVER AND THEY ARE DENYING
THAT.
THAT IS ONE OF THE RULES OF HOW
THIS GAME IS ACTUALLY PLAYED.
I THINK IT IS EVEN WORSE.
>> JACK DORSEY ISN'T DOING IT T
MAKE AN EXTRA BUCK.
HE HAS ENOUGH BUCKS.
SOME OF THESE GUYS WERE DOING I
AUTHENTICALLY ARE EVEN WORSE.
>> EXERCISED UNDUE INFLUENCE OF
THE MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH.
>> I HAVE A QUESTION.
BACKING OFF FOR THE A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAID HERE, THEY'RE NOT
REALLY DOING ANYTHING.
I HEAR ABOUT A LOT OF SEMINARS.
AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND IT, YOU
SIT THERE.
IF THEY REALLY CARED, BUT THESE
PEOPLE VOLUNTEER AND WHY ARE
PEOPLE CALLING THEM OUT ON THAT.
A LOT OF IT IS THEY MAKE PEOPLE
OPERATE.
HOW TO PEOPLE GET BEYOND THE
SPHERE OF THINGS OF SENIOR NOT
REALLY WOKE.
YOU'RE JUST LISTENING TO
SOMEBODY SAY CRAZY STUFF.
>> IT IS THE SPHERE.
CORPORATE AMERICA, THE WAY IT
WORKS, YOU WOULD RATHER HEAR ME
TALKING ABOUT WOKE VALUES AND
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION OR
HARDING --
THEN YOU WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
OCCUPY WALL STREET, WHICH IS
WHEN I THINK ALL THIS BEGAN,
AFTER THE FINANCIAL CRISIS, WAL
STREET WAS SCARED OF OCCUPY WAL
STREET.
GETTING ON THE WOKE VALUES WAS
EASY.
THAT'S WHEN ALL THIS BEGAN, THE
AFTER EFFECT OF WHAT IS HAPPENE
SINCE THEN.
>> I WAS TAKEN BY WHAT I SAW AN
A LITTLE PREVIEW WHERE YOU
TALKED ABOUT WOKISM BEING USED
AS A GEOPOLITICAL TOOL.
CAN YOU EXPAND ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE QUICK.
>> THE WAY IT WORKS IN CHINA IS
THEY WILL BUILD A GREAT CHINESE
WALLS THAT PREVENTS YOU FROM
ENTERING THE CHINESE MARKET.
THEY PEOPLE FOR THE RED CARPET
IF YOU CRITICIZE THE UNITED
STATES.
DISNEY'S THAT THEY COULDN'T FIL
IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA AND
GEORGIA PASSES AND ANTIABORTION
STATUTE THAT THEY TELL THEM WE
LINE IN, WHICH IS GROUND ZERO O
THE HUMAN RIGHTS CRISIS AND
ACTUALLY PRAISE THEM.
WITH THAT ALLOWS CHINA TO DO IS
WHEN THEY GET PRESS AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUES BY THE UN AND EU,
BLACK LACE BETTER SHOW THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS NO BETTER, THE
INTERNATIONAL ARBITER SUFFER
INJUSTICE THAT SUPPOSEDLY
CORPORATIONS ARE PRAISING CHINA
WHILE THEY ARE CRITICIZING THE
UNITED STATES.
I THINK THAT IS DANGEROUS
GEOPOLITICALLY.
IT UNDERLINES THEIR ARSENAL AND
IT IS THEIR MORAL STANDING ON
THE GLOBAL STAGE.
>> EXCEPTIONALISM.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I CAN'T WAIT TO WATCH THE SHOW,
READ THE BOO